um this is a scheduled work
session of the house election law
committee um
and before we get started i'm gonna ask
everybody to join me in the
pledge i know in the room they have a
flag there i do if you do if you could
please join me
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
thank you everybody all right um
i am going to do the the standard
reading for an electronic meeting
um this is a hybrid meeting as has been
noticed in the house calendar we're
asking that members who are using
devices to please mute
and turn off your sound to avoid
feedback consider
turning off your video if you intend to
use the keyboard for taking notes
it's important for members to speak
clearly with some volume
soft voices may be heard but hard to
understand and microphones in rooms pick
up sound very well be careful about
side conversations i have an
announcement about a lunch break but i
have no
anticipation that we will need any
information about a lunch break today
um the sign up sheet in regards to
today's hearing stopped accepting i
don't even know that they did a sign up
sheet because this is noticed as a work
session we've already had sign up sheets
for these bills you should all have a
copy of them
um as to today's meeting as chair of the
house election law committee i find that
due to the state of emergency declared
by the governor as a result of the covet
19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order 12
pursuant to executive order
2020.04 this body is authorized to meet
today is a work session on bills
referred to the committee and scheduled
in the house calendar for today
an executive session will not be held
today
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i'm confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
embarrassingly during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participating in this
meeting by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar
on the general court website the notice
for this meeting complies with house
rules and rsa 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing this
meeting should call 271-3600
or email hcs at ledge.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access this meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
and we will start this meeting by taking
a roll call
attendance um representative mcdonald
has volunteered to step in
for natalie wells who was unavailable
for today
and representative mooney has
volunteered to be
back up in case we have to switch roles
uh i'm not sure i
see representative mooney here yet
um there is a chance i have a fairly bad
internet connection where i am
so if i have to drop off representative
mcdonald's will be taking over the
meeting
so with that uh representative mcdonald
if you could do a roll call for me that
would be terrific
can everyone hear me yes yep yep
okay thanks uh representative uh this is
representative bergeron
i'm present i'm participating remotely
from my home in nashua
and there's no one else in the home with
me at the present time
thank you representative barry i am
president of my home in manchester and
as per usual i am alone and probably
will be joined by my cats at some point
thank you representative cody
i'm here in nashua and i'm alone thank
you
representative freitas i am here in
manchester new hampshire and i'm alone
in my home
good morning good morning thank you good
morning
uh good morning i am participating
remotely i'm in south carolina there is
no one with two legs with me right now
thank you representative
i am president in my office at work no
one else is
in the room representative hamlet
i am president i am in my home in
portsmouth and there's another family
member in the house
thank you representative hamer
i am president in my home in manchester
and just four-legged animals with me
she had something else today okay so she
is out okay
representative mcdonald i am here in the
committee room in concord
representative mooney here in the llb
committee room in concord thank you
representative i'm in hanover new
hampshire in a room by myself
and a house with other people working
thank you
she's if she might be calling in by
phone she's going to be limited
participation
okay thank you representative
i'm here in my home and rindge my home
office uh by myself
just taking the role marker is here even
if we can't hear it
okay our representative strange is
clearly here
am present i am in my office in concord
uh there's no one else in this room with
me there are two other people in the
building
thank you representative
zoom by myself actually i'm in sales
place i do a little bit part-time work
in the uh
in the storage room by myself thank you
representative i don't think he i think
no
i don't i don't expect to see
representative ward okay
thank you and representative wells we
know is absent
we have um ian president madam chairman
and it looks like uh former president
george w bush might be in the room with
representative sweeney can we check on
that
[Laughter]
i don't even want to ask who some
what similar people might be with
members of the committee today so there
yeah let's not go down this path folks
all right
um so i
i want to thank you all for
noticed this for a work session
primarily because we have experienced
at least for my memory in election law
that
are an introduction to omnibus bills
and when we got to
an executive session i wanted the
committee to have
some direction on how to address them
because
i have no ice bills are going um
i have my own opinion on where they
should go
but that is not going to affect how the
committee goes forward
um and if people feel strongly that one
section of the bill should
survive so to speak with amendment i
want to make sure that the committee has
the ability to preserve
that piece of the omnibus bill
and not have it be subject to what else
might be going on
in the rest of the bill um so that was
really the focus of it i want to thank
attorney bergeron for an attorney hamlet
for doing an amendment uh to a section
before today but the other thing is is
if it appears
that people want to do amendments they
can
and i'm getting noticed that my internet
connection is unstable so we are going
to move
right along the first bill
we have is s31 that was relative to
voter checklist and modifying
the absentee ballot affidavit
we had a public hearing on this bill on
march
31st and it
modifies the actions
of supervisors i think really as
compared to the secretary of state
um and so it sort of eliminated
language in the process saying it was on
the envelope and in the affidavit why
did we need it to
um and that's sort of my general
overview of what this bill did
i have a couple of sections um
noted where people had specific
questions so i guess i would just like
to open this up
to committee members to see if they had
any particular comments or
or things about this bill that they
yes madam chairman um
heywood wants to say something thank you
representative haywood go ahead
there is uh 112
through 14. an attempt to
try and bring
the emergency orders into
in the uh current law the first part of
line 12 why am i able to vote a person
with a disability
is actually not new that is that
shouldn't be highlighted
that is what it says in our senate it's
representative hayward are we on hb
third sb31
yes h3
okay thank you i was on the wrong page
thank you my internet was bad
sorry go ahead i would uh
suggest that we strike
from the second sentence in that line
the disability includes medical
conditions
i would agree with that that would be an
amendment that would get
so if you wanted to bring that forward
that would come come as an amendment to
sb31
all right anybody else have any
comps on sb 31 or questions in regards
to the impact or what it was trying to
do
madam chair oh i'm sorry representative
bergeron you had your hand up thank you
go ahead
thank you and and it'll be quick in your
introduction you had mentioned that
some members of the committee had
mentioned why is certain language
appearing in two statutes
i happen to be the one that raised the
question on page one lines eight through
ten
uh why was that included in rsa 654
colon 45
addresses the same thing and frankly i
don't have
a strong opinion one way or the other
whether that language is duplicated here
as well or not so
i don't think it's really an issue in my
opinion on that section
all right thank you i did have the note
i didn't have your name on
i also had that somebody concluded it it
at least doesn't conflict with the other
statute is that correct
uh that's correct and actually may
clarify
on line nine it says uh supervisors
shall enter the data
whereas rsa 654 colon 45
says that the voter registration form
shall include
the data so maybe in some ways it
actually helps clarify
what the roles of the supervisor should
be
all right um
any comments on the introduction of uh
on line 22 page one
all right so as to s31
um i'm hearing the possibility of an
amendment deleting a particular
provision
um but in general not any other specific
comments
if anybody objects to that conclusion
all right we're going to move on to then
sb46
sb46 is relative to the use of
electronic
poll books by cities and towns we had a
public hearing
on this on march 31st
there was a fair amount of discussion on
i'm not particularly sure i saw anything
in regards to
changes but let me open it up to
committee members in regards to the
language on this bill and what it's
proposing to do
um just to recap there's a trial program
now
it's basically bringing it into the
ability to do it
um on a regular basis i heard somebody
somebody in election
in the lob no i was getting ready to say
something
uh madame chair it's uh peter terrorism
i um
i got bumped off here i got represented
yeah i got weakened in that too um i
know
when we heard testimony on that part of
that bill
um the secretary of state's office was
concerned with the
with the time frame of implementing this
at this time
so that was there was some concerns
there from
from from them they they don't disagree
with the uh concept but
felt that um it couldn't be done in the
time
that uh would be stipulated in the in
and i don't know if i'm still there or
not because i'm definitely fading in and
out here
well i would just note that if there's
any consideration of change of the
effective date the date of the repeal
should probably also be changed because
you would want the trial program to be
able to remain in effect for those
right and it could be it is
and i'm not suggesting that whether we
um
i got mixed emotions about it quite
frankly we could either amend it or we
could
we could strike that section down and
okay
i don't care i believe i heard
i believe i heard representative
taurosian uh refer to
yeah maybe i'm not again i i was got
bumped up it took me a while to get back
on what one way on then i thought we
46. all right yeah i'm not there was
some concern about the tap
that's all right i'll periodically say
what bill we're on because a couple of
us have an
unstable problem i can't pull that one
up
i have 83 and 89 here in paper but that
i don't i can't
uh it knocked me off so i i don't have
the uh have that bill in front of me
um anybody care to give me a very short
that's all right then when we get to it
okay
um i will just note that
we can make this effective right away
but from a municipal standpoint
the requirement is for the municipality
who wants to do this
procures the poll
book themselves um
the trial community was able to use
some on a trial basis with the vendor
but as far as going forward this is
going to be a municipal budget item
for communities i know in
towns and cities we are certainly past
the date
for budgets for this calendar year
so the impact would be on budgets for
next year i don't know exactly i think
the city process is slightly different
than towns
um but just so people understand this is
clearly something that would have to be
budgeted by your
municipality
so that will be a consideration in the
effect
airman i see that all right i see
representative
yep i made madam chair
go ahead representative bergeron and
then
deputy scanlon i would just uh
mention too that while it's true that
the commun communities will need to come
up with the funding
to purchase the poll books it is
optional
some of the larger communities the large
towns large cities
may embrace the idea some of the smaller
communities may not
but it's uh you know a bunch of
consideration that they
thank you for that reminder deputy
scanlon thank you madam chair i i just
wanted to add a little clarity
um uh this office is fine with the time
frame
in senate bill 46. uh
representative perot mentioned senate
bill 83 and he is correct
that that section of of that bill uh
we didn't be concerned about the
effectiveness
members
i'm not seeing any so we'll move
on to sb 54.
this is relative to the absentee ballot
application for
again this was another public hearing
that occurred
on march 31st and it's
a requirement that absentee
ballot applications include
some identity information
it is uh with some changes
and new sections comment from committee
members
representative bergeron well thank you
madam chair
i polled the city clerks because i
wanted to find out how many city clerks
did not have access to the dmv database
because in a lot of the cities
motor vehicle registration is handled by
tax collectors or finance directors
nashville portsmouth manchester berlin
and rochester all said they don't have
access to dmv
information but the clerks in claremont
and laconia also pointed out to me
that while they process motor vehicle
registrations
they don't have access to the driver's
license or non
driver's license id number so even those
communities that have access to a
dmv through their motor vehicle
registration process
don't have the means to verify
a voter's driver's license or
non-driver's picture id number
the other piece is that senator gray the
sponsor
talked about the possibility of maybe a
clerk verifying
a voter's identity using the vital
records database
and there is a search fee involved with
that anytime the clerk logs in
and does a search for a vital record the
state charges eight dollars for that
search
and that's passed on to the citizen
who's at the counter asking for
a birth certificate for example and it's
assessed whether or not the record is
found
so if that were to be a means whereby
a clerk would have to verify a person's
identity
then the voter registration database
needs to be amended
or revised or recoded so that
there's no fee associated with accessing
that that database
i just wanted to share that information
thank you representative bergeron for
looking into that further for the
committee
representative barry um actually i think
representative bergeron hit on the um
with this statement here on the point
that i agree with which is that if we do
implement something like this we can't
create a new
burden on the towns um i'm not too
familiar with this database
um to be to be upfront and how would
they charge this eight dollar fee
um knowing kind of how databases work it
seems like it's
probably not necessary for them to do
that here but that was a little beyond
my scope but
except representative bergeron kind of
all right so it sounds like that's
an issue and we'd need an amendment to
go to the vital records
regardless and i think you're right
senator gray did mention that
can i make a comment madam chair
sure representative derozan go ahead
thank you
yeah uh and and i know that was when we
had testimony on that bill there was
some concern about
how to make that work on the vital
record and how valuable that would be
but certainly i like the concept of
bringing uh absentee ballot um
you know identification more in line
with what
what we do now at the polls currently
when you when you show up to vote in
person
um you have to for the most part you
have to show your driver's license or
or you know
some kind of proper identification
and i i heard firsthand from my town
clerks in the two towns i represent that
um
with absentee balloting that was kind of
it flew under the radar that you didn't
have to show
um an id when you came in in person like
you do when you when you
vote in person so i like the idea of
bringing that
into a more consistent um condition
um than we have now whether or not we
can achieve that with this bill
i guess we'll have to see but but i i
like that aspect of it
madam chair are there comments i know
that
representative growing it could
could we also uh amend to
allow the clerk's access to the dmv
records
for purposes of of the absentee ballots
and voter checklist
my guess is representative cody might
have more experience or representative
bergeron with this issue but my guess is
and this is a guess at this point that
we would also need to
amend a statute relating to dmv
uh yes ma'am because we would be
allowing it on one end
but not authorizing dmv representative
cody
i said i was confirming that you were
correct
and i and there are other reasons that
might not be advisable
okay i mean if
if that's how somebody wants to do it
you're you're
you can do an amendment for that but i
do think that
you would have dmv at this point saying
i don't have the authority to release it
and i and i don't know whether represent
whether senator gray's reference to
access
implied that and i note that the dmv
director is attending and
if or someone from that office is
attending and if they would
like to speak
i would love i am going to uh
certainly allow them to um
or if there's somebody who has any
specific information on this if they
wanted to
speak up we'd be welcome we'd be happy
to hear from them
good morning madam chair this is
elizabeth fielecki from the dmv
um i can i can shine
me too i'm sorry and i was just thinking
this is sb 46 so um
i was just looking at um the bill
i'm not familiar with we're actually
director we're actually on
sb 54. okay
let me look back at that um but i know
that you're looking at
access court access to dmv record you
are absolutely
correct that we would probably adjust
the driver privacy act for that specific
um circumstance as well in addition we
would really have to work to see how the
records would be shared as well um
because there is really not an
electronic exchange of records with
the courts right now so there might be
some logistical challenges with that as
well
i'm happy to explore it farther but i
think you would have to look at the dpa
or the driver privacy act to provide
some specific exemptions for release of
thank you very much for joining us and
for that clarification
is there anybody else who wants to speak
on this particular issue or the bill
we're on which is
sb 54. and
i see representative lane joins us good
morning
okay
all right the next bill that we have
before is from the senate as a committee
is sb 83 sb 83
is adoption of omnibus legislation
relative to elections the public hearing
on this bill
was april 23rd
there are five sections to the bill
clarifying the circumstances of
disqualification for performing duties
as an election official
relative to the establishment of an
election information portal
the third section is relative to recount
fees the fourth section
is relative to statements filed by
political candidates and
committees and the fifth one
is providing for optional town meeting
procedures i had some
anticipation that this bill and
89 might have very specific
um comments as to different parts and
because they're
not related this is really
one of the primary purposes of the work
session is to sort of figure out what
might be happening with these bills so
if we can i would like to proceed by
part since they are so independent
so taking a look at sb 83
part 1 this has to do with sort of
a statute that apparently has had a few
amendments
um in regards to who can actually handle
ballots and
the moderator seems to be the the word
of import
in this particular section
representative trojan thank you madam
chair
i like the idea and concept because um
most of us in our districts are probably
at one point or another had a moderator
who's
also running for you know a state
position
say you know a house seat and certainly
their ability to have and i know this
this
bill doesn't address this portion it has
to do with when they're counting
votes but um we have to follow very
specific rules on being so far
away from the voters when we're
campaigning but if you're a moderator
you get to be right there in the thick
of things so
i conceptually i like the idea however
there's a problem with this and we heard
that in testimony that
um the moderator has specific duties
that are outlined in the constant
the constitution that would
be a problem if we were past this part
one because
um i'm not so sure he can delegate this
would
require him to delegate and i'm not so
sure that
that that is allowed under the way that
statue is written i'd be
interested to know what other people
representative bergeron i know you don't
have your hand up but i know
you're very familiar with this
this statue
and yeah you know i mentioned to some
other members of the committee that have
been dealing with this issue for 48
years
um and we still haven't gotten involved
um
because i i was i won an election at
state rep 48 years ago in a
in a recount and immediately introduce
legislation saying
no candidate could count ballots at the
polling place regardless of their
positions
um what i was looking at when i raised
it is that
the second part article 32 of the
constitution says
that the procedure shall be governed by
a moderator who
that's their constitutional authority
and directive
i do think the moderator can apply an
assistant moderator to work in his stead
one of the things that concerns me
though is
this law is also saying that they can't
be in the area designated for the
handling of marked ballots for the
counting of votes which
currently kind of means everything
within the guard rail
and so you're throwing the moderator
outside of the guard rail
um during the counting and and you know
the closing
the polls essentially and that's a
concern i i don't know how to address it
um so i share some of the concerns of
rep
representative trojan um there is a
there is some kind of conflict here
and how best to resolve it i frankly
representative barry um yes i actually
had a
question of representative bergeron if
he'd be willing to take one
sure um you said that you've been
working on this problem
for a while and i i definitely see the
problem i'm not it's
it's not an easy uh an easy one i just
wanted you to go over
kind of some of the solutions that have
been proposed in the past
i'm not familiar with them so i just
kind of curious what
the initial bill i introduced in 73 said
essentially that nobody could work at
the polls who was a candidate on the
ballot
that went to a study committee it came
out saying that
over the years it's been changed senator
jasper
representative jasper introduced a bill
saying that
the moderators and these election
officials could work at the polls
provided they didn't count or handle
the challenge is that we as elected
officials want to make sure that
the public perceives the elections being
handled in a fair
impartial manner and when you have a
candidate
at the polling place counting his or her
own ballots it becomes
[Music]
well it becomes fodder for conspiracy
theories if you will
um i thought it was a great idea in the
70s when i introduced it
later on when when i became city clerk i
thought it was a terrible idea
because we were excluding some of the
most experienced people
uh from working at the polls in some
very large elections
and and i don't know what the solution
is here really
right now we're at the point where the
only elected official who seems to be
allowed in that area
to handle and and count ballots is the
moderator
if we throw that person out um
i guess we have to make sure that it's
clear that that person can appoint an
assistant moderator
representative barry if you want to
continue go ahead yeah
just to kind of expand that i wasn't
even kind of thinking
about the counting of ballots because
admittedly my experience in voting in
new hampshire is manchester where
there's
you know about the um the poll location
is extremely busy there's people
everywhere
right um it would be hard for somebody
to do something nefarious i've never
really
really conceptualized that but i guess
in these smaller towns you're you're
right you know these are kind of
lowercase fairs i've always
i've always had the thought about these
moderators working inside these polls
one of the things and this may already
be a law i'm not aware of it if it is
but
i've always been concerned that they're
going to wear something like like a name
badge or something like that and they'll
be inside the guardrail helping people
vote and there's their name on a badge
right there then the voter sees that and
you know that's a last minute name
recognition tick and it's a campaign
advantage
um so kind of kind of interesting the
way you're going about this or the way
you're thinking about it
it's a new thought process for me so
thanks
if i'm well thank you representative
barry for that because i didn't even
think about the name tag issue that
hadn't even crossed my mind
because most people in my town know each
other but you're right even the name tag
would
have some impact representative bergeron
yeah i would just add that even if the
moderator isn't
technically counting the ballots when
the accu vote machines are being used
the moderator
will get involved perhaps in the hand
count of ballots certainly the
processing of absentee ballots
and maybe maybe making rulings on the
intent of the voter in
in ballots that some of the election
officials might have questions on when
tallying them
the name badge certainly is is a
consideration
um and it's a
i don't have an answer i don't have an
answer
representative taurosian thank you madam
chair
um and again it seems as though we
maybe don't have a clear solution
forward on this
but just to reiterate some of the
problems the um
you know you know in a town election
some um any selectmen that are up for
re-election or
or anybody that's running i would have
to be up for re-election they're not
allowed to
to um in our town i don't know if this
happens everywhere
to participate in in work or shift
during the polls
when they were on the ballot so it seems
to
you know and then that's for a good
reason so it seems like we should carry
it
a step further with the moderator
however in my district in one of my
towns
both the moderator and the assistant
moderator are both um
current state reps so but so if you said
okay the moderator can't do it well he
with a system moderator is also a wrap
so you know it's problematic i i too
would like to find a way forward on this
but i don't know that this
this part one of uh sb 83s is
is the answer
representative moorehead as i
as i listened to uh more experienced you
know committee members discuss this i
guess
my takeaway is that there's a benefit to
excluding moderators
it eliminates a conflict of interest it
eliminates an unfair advantage and maybe
most important it eliminates the
perception of an unfair advantage
but there's also a cost in that a lot of
moderators
who also happen to be maybe candidates
for state rep
are among the most experienced election
officials that towns have
and and so we're just weighing this
benefit in the cost and
and i'm trying to get my mind around you
know how big a cost that is
and anyone who can speak to that you
know i'd be
grateful to hear from um you know are
there a lot of state reps who are
moderators
are there a lot of towns that would
suffer if we disallowed
state rep slash moderators from
participating
in uh the administration of an election
how big is this cost
and i don't i know no one may be able to
answer it but i'm just that that's what
i'm trying to
wrap my mind around as i'm weighing the
cost and the benefit
i see that deputy scanlon is still
online with us and i guess if
he would be willing i'd i'd like him to
answer
from as to your
office how often has
this issue been raised by members of the
public with concern
madam chair every election we hear
from voters about uh
uh local election officials working the
polls
uh sometimes when they're running for
the same office but certainly
when they're running for an office other
than an election official
and uh you know i mean people feel
different ways about that
and um and there are perception
issues that are involved and you know
when we train local election officials
we do everything we can to make them
aware
of uh you know those potential uh
perception issues that might be out
there while they're doing
their job um and as has been discussed
by the committee this has been
a subject uh not just this year but
you know as representative bergeron said
for decades
and obviously there's been no resolution
to you know how to
easily address the concerns
the one thought i guess i would convey
to the committee
is that these individuals
that are serving as moderators or
supervisors of the checklist that
you know hold other positions and there
are a number of state reps
that are also moderators currently
is that they are elected by the people
in their
town or in their ward and those
positions are usually ones
that command respect um
the the the officials are chosen based
on their
integrity and honesty and and
and the voters decision that they're
capable of doing the job
and and you know every example that i
can think of
that where a current state rep also
serves as a moderator
i think they're all excellent examples
of individuals that are able to separate
uh you know running for an office but
also doing their job
as an election official and and even
though there's
you know this issue comes up you know
every
every biennium uh we seem to get through
it and
you know i'm not aware of any real
scandals that are out there
uh that i can cite as examples of you
know this process going awry
because of conflicts beyond that you
know i i don't have any
answers on you know how to cleanly
address this
representative hamer do you have your
hand up
or do i have my cursor over your screen
i have
i think we understand the issue when
it's an issue representative
your head well i just would propose for
people to consider that if it really is
a vexing question
and it's been it's been dogging people
you know for 50 i i
remember our esteemed colleague
representative bergeron for
five decades you know maybe rather than
pass the bill in its per current state
we should um
we should take this little one part of
it and study it uh just a little bit
longer
and and get a sense of how many people
are talking about how many times be
affected
um and and and just get a more precise
understanding of
of what the effects of this would be for
towns in the state
and i'm not sure that's the right course
all right i just um thank you for
raising that because it brings up two
points that are my understanding of
dealing with these omnivorous bills
just so you know we cannot separate the
parts out
they remain in the final
vote on what will be sb
83 now amended by the senate
possibly amended by the house so
you're considering say part one is a
study
it needs to be contained an amendment
within the bill
and cannot be retained or dealt with
separately it it is part of the whole
package which is part of why i wanted to
have this work session
so that people understood when
amendments come forward you're dealing
with that
that part and you can make a motion to
amend the bill to delete a part um
so you understand that's valid so you
can delete amend
or leave a part in we can't create a new
bill
thank you madam chair i just wanted to
say you you've had a good historical
overview of the
current state of the situation regarding
this question which has been a question
as representative bergeron pointed out
for longer than i've been around
uh and i've always been one that's come
down on the side of you know that you
have to pick your poison
in terms of you know you either want to
run for state rep or you want to do
moderator
um i concede that that uh
representative bergeron and others have
raised significant questions about
about the utility of that in these
circumstances
um but uh
you know obviously if this were not a
live issue it wouldn't be here
and but the only thing i could say about
it is i
have no uh answers any more than anyone
else has however
you know at some point you have to at
some point you have to fish or cut bait
as my grandfather used to
say thank you
thank you all right any other committee
comments on part one
madam chair we are on sb
83 representative growing yeah regarding
uh representative merhead's suggestion
could there be an amendment just to make
section one a study instead of
i it can but i think my reply is
how many times do you study an issue it
sounds like this has been
studied maybe not by virtue of a formal
separate committee but it's certainly
been discussed a lot
um and i think representative cody makes
a valid point maybe some people just
have to make a decision i know in my
community
the moderator has always just been the
moderator
um and we've had about three moderators
since the beginning of time
um and maybe that has something to do
with the
how that election goes and that he's
handling ballots in my community once
you become moderator
you're there till you don't want to run
anymore or god has other plans for you
so and i know a lot of the communities
around me are like that
so
you know committee members can bring
what amendments they want forward but
i just want everybody to understand what
representative teroshian for their
comment yeah thank you madam chair
no i i concur with what you were just
saying um i mentioned
one of my towns uh having the assistant
moderator and the moderator both
state reps in my town my current
moderator
was a state rep but he takes very
seriously
his job as moderator to be completely
impartial to the point where he was a
registered republican he he no longer
associates with a
party he goes out of his way to to to
to make sure there's no indication or
[Music]
potential for there to be a conflict
interest and
so certainly you know people make that
choice maybe that's the
solution to with the future legislation
to come up with a way to maybe perhaps
have that kind of restriction
but it's getting back to part one it
seems to me the best thing we could do
with that is
is to um is to i tell that portion of
the bill
in its current form it's just my opinion
at this point
all right i assume you're talking about
part one of representative friedas
it's been my ex that the experience of
the moderator is what keeps this
election running smoothly
and legally and i think it's rare i
don't know
no somebody said there were two
representatives that are in my ward i
would prefer that
to be what it is that the moderator who
is running for another position
cannot touch in fact that happens i
cannot touch the ballots when they're
counting them
so it's i i would leave it as it is
are you disclosing that you're a
moderator
no i'm not a moderator i don't think i
want to be okay
no um and because we have one that is
so good it's so experienced why would i
want to
lose that because he's running for
something and
how many days does the moderator serve
in that role as compared to a
representative
i just need a good mod and i have one
all right well so anything we pass will
be except for the good moderator and
representative frieda's
district all right
all right part two of sb 83
is in regards to the establishment of an
election
information portal
there were a fair amount of discussion
on this
there was some question as to whether or
not there should have been a fiscal note
associated with it um and
uh the the end
the end goal bill was that a
information portal um would be
in place by january 1st of next year
representative terozian thanks again
madam chair
um yes and this was the one i i was
speaking to before when we were on uh
one of the other bills um because i
thought we had gone further ahead
and so in you heard uh deputy
uh scanlon say that um that
there was some concern on the on the uh
on the date
uh the prime sponsor in this did
indicate that he
wouldn't have a problem if we chose to
push the date dates out
and i think almost certainly if we had
an interest in passing that we would
have to do that
but i believe i might have been one that
asked the question about the fiscal note
on that or the
what the cost would be and that was a
concern as well so
those are the two issues i see with with
that i don't disagree in concept with
the idea but whether or not
as it's drafted we can get there on this
i'm not sure
uh madam chair representative terezian
did you want to add something
no i was trying to i i i tried to lower
my hand i might have hit it twice
no i'm all set all right representative
growing did you have something
yeah could uh deputy scanlon
comment on what an appropriate date
deputy scanlan thank you madam chair um
i think that it is um
too optimistic to think that we might
have a portal
uh like this in place for the 22
election cycle but
is something that i think is certainly
doable for
2024 so you know if that's the time
frame that the committee would
want to look at i think that's certainly
something that we could
deputy scaling i guess i have a question
for you
um
there was some question about whether
who who would actually be doing this at
least in my mind i have some notes to
that effect
and this directs that
your office with uh the department of
information technology
was there some financial
implications of this i would presume and
was there some
other department that maybe should have
or would be involved in this
as i call all right
deputy scandal technology the language
uh in the bill um suggests that we work
with the department of information
technology
when we're designing the portal um and
you know that's something certainly be
happy to do
uh typically when there's ft project
i'll call it you know we
we establish the parameters um
of what's going to be requested uh put
it in the form of an rfp
and then have some vendors uh
you know submit their proposals on
making the implementation of it happen
and
um to do that obviously we have to rely
on some expertise
of i.t professionals which
um and that leads then to the question
of the fiscal note you know once we
do that uh you know we get bids in yeah
we have a better handle of how much
this is actually going to cost uh based
does anybody know whether the current
general
house website has what we would consider
a true portal on it
because from what i know these are
pretty much static
pages that provide links to documents
or
i think that exactly i don't believe we
do have anything
um like a portal on the house
on the general court website
yeah i don't think we do either and i
raise that just because i know
um for other reasons i'm looking at
websites and i know what our
staffing is and our current technology
as compared to what other places might
have in regards to portals
and information and staff because i'll
so i have a major concern with this and
then when
we put in a date of the end of next
session
you know not that i think this section
would be undone but i'm not sure that
that's
a practice i want to get into because
in two years from now and i don't think
this is an issue that it would be
the next session could come in and say
be gone
and now you've directed people
on a path that maybe internally if they
had just done
would still be in place but by statute
we could potentially
all right well it sounds like
there's not general opposition to it but
there is some
general at the implementation and the
date
okay section three
of sb 83
where part three has to do with recount
fees
it was pretty straightforward it was
presented by senator gray questions or
comments
representative lane yeah sorry i can't
figure out how to raise my hand
um my comment was
and maybe it's just it's gonna cost
uh a senator more to
do a recount they're gonna make during
their term
and it's going to count and it's going
to cost state rep almost the same amount
it i don't know it just kind of hit me
wrong but
i guess that's the price of
it just seems i don't know
odd are you are you talking about
section three with the state
senator and state representative yes
but and i was just it just seemed
incongruent i mean
it's i mean we're basically public
servants we're making 100 bucks a year
it just i don't know seemed odd but
representative barry i mean i actually
had the the opposite feeling
um i i wished uh i wish they were higher
um i think a lot of the re i've
participated in a lot of recounts in the
state
probably over 15 at this point including
municipal recounts
which are covered by this but um right
usually usually i probably in my
personal experience probably 70 percent
of the recounts i've participated
in are grossly unnecessary rarely ever
with windham excluded the current
situation wyndham excluded
do the results change um and a lot of
times these are
these are feel good exercises for the
losing candidate and by the way i've
worked for both the winning and the
losing candidates so
i understand what it's like to be on
both sides of that um
um i i hear you about the state reps and
the state senators um
you know i i i look at the i look more
of the concern
with the statewide and congressional
districts
um and the cost associated with those
the secretary of state's office does an
excellent job on these recounts they
spend
a lot of money and staff on these
recounts and one of these days
we will have a statewide recount and i
have no idea what the cost will be but
it will be high
you know in 2016 the u.s senate race was
decided by a little more than a thousand
votes
um and that would have been a perfectly
reasonable recount to ask for
um given the margin right um so i guess
i i raised all that to say i'm kind of
on the other side of that but i have no
intention of changing it but if somebody
does change it to be higher
representative representative
thank you thanks again madam chair yeah
um
i was going to comment um um and uh
representative barry kind of hit on it
that
i mean if you look at the old uh fee
schedule if you want to call it that
um what a rep paid was less
for a recount than a state senate race
so it's always been that way um you know
and i
and i to add to what um
representative berry said his concern is
a statewide and congressional
so you know maybe a solution to that of
people concerned about
you leave the fee the same for for the
house and
state senate maybe even executive
council and and then the rest
you do the increase i i don't really
have heartburn either way
other than i'm typically people that
know me know i i'm up
more often than not i vote against
things that are that are fee increases
because that's just the way i am but um
you know and i don't know what the cost
of
what it costs to do a recount i know
there's a lot of volunteers if
we if we're woefully behind the cost
then we should increase it
again this was another section of the
bill that there was no fiscal note
we're already doing it so i'm assuming
the response would have been
no discernible change representative
growing
[Music]
thank you madam chair i agree with
representative barry on this
uh i think the even with the raised
fees i'm sure that even with the
increased fees it comes nowhere near the
cost
of the recount uh the point here
it seems is to the the greater the
margin the higher the cost to discourage
people from from doing a um you know
asking for a recount if
if there's a larger margin and
i think the numbers are very reasonable
it you know what with the state rep
candidate i agree that it's a
low paid position but i can't imagine
uh very many state reps spending less
than
10 or 20 times these amounts on their
campaigns
i don't think the amount if they really
want to recount would
prevent them from doing it but it would
representative barry i mean i just want
to add
one more point about the state rep
recount um not all state rep recounts
are created equal
um some districts are heads up you know
we're talking about less than a thousand
voters maybe 1200 voters
um in my district i have one of the
largest filterial seats in terms of
population in the state i've got about i
think
18 000 registered voters um so
those recounts are different a recount
in dairy where there's i believe there's
almost there's over eight reps in dairy
now those multi-candidate recounts
get really really labor-intensive
because you're having to count you're
not just recounting
the the the first win the last winner
and the first loser right you're
recounting
everything in there um so if those those
okay somebody wants to make amendments
it sounds like in general there's not
if they're not overwhelming opposition
and there might be some
appetite for changing some of the fees
so make your amendments appropriately if
you're going to
part 4 of sb 83 is relative to the
itemized statements
filed by political committees and
candidate um
what was used to submit to the secretary
of state
and ross barry was close to my heart on
this in regards to saying that even
size 8 was not big enough it should be
12.
representative barry um to that uh
um madam chairman um i i did send an
amendment over to you from ols i do have
the uh fabled uh eight point font to
twelve point font amendment from ols
ready to go um it's my intention with
that amendment
that if we edit this uh omnibus bill
that i'll present it
if we don't for some reason edit this
ominous bill which i think is an
unlikely situation i'll just sit on it
um i don't want to have to needlessly
send this bill back to the senate if
thank you representative teresian
thank you madam chair um so
i'm one that and i'm not alone um
i'm more of a grassroots guy and i don't
have a team
when i run for state rep and i suspect
there's a lot of others and i do
file my um reports
um you know oftentimes i even fax them
and they're handwritten but you can read
them and i don't want
you know it's problematic to me it's
just one more thing i have to do
um and others like me now i have to
you know spend more time filing these
things if i have to
have them all formatted on on the
computer and and i'll go on record as
being the dumbest guy when it comes to
computers
in the room and so that
you know the rest of it i'm fine with it
should it should be
legible but i don't want to be forced to
have to to
to do more work on these things because
what i do
submit is legible and it and then
they're handwritten
and i do it myself that's all so
let other members of the committee
correct me i understand this is a may
that if you're doing it electronically
you have to do it in a manner that's
legible that that was the
intent it wasn't to force you to file it
electronically if you didn't want to
so somebody deputy scanlan you're on the
line could you uh
chime in as to whether that's your
understanding of this bill or not
uh yes ma'am chair my understanding is
just to make the forums
legible
but if people are doing hand written
they can continue to do that that's my
understanding
just want to make sure that thank you if
they are handwritten that they are also
legible
well thank you for the for the
clarification because i thought i heard
in testimony that this would force
everybody to have to do them
electronically
perhaps i'm on a misnomer there yeah
that was not my understanding
yes yes uh
representative teresa and i just wanted
to point out that it's explicit
on line 22
uh page four for part four
that uh a candidate the political
committee of a candidate
or a candidate may file such candidates
required reports
as an email attachment a facsimile or a
so i think that makes it very clear that
you can continue
to file on paper okay
so the new section the new section on
line twenty eight just based
thank you madame for the comments on
part four
i'm not seeing any um so that sounds
like that i'm
i'm sorry mr representative lane sorry
go ahead should go back sorry i need to
look for your wave
i i i did it physically not
to representative quality's point the
way i read that though is even with the
paper copy
it says provided that the font size
still would be required correct
but most people are going to write big
points
so i think roman numeral 1 would still
apply but roman numeral two and three
probably wouldn't is that a correct
reading is that how you would read that
that's my understanding i didn't
particularly
i don't think that the facsimile your
paper copy i think you can print out
on the forum and that would technically
be electronic but
um i understood that i think i recall in
testimony that
you know some of the filings they would
make the font size purposely small
so that you couldn't read it as printed
and then you would have to
go to another you know medium so
i understood that you could still do
them hand written and this really
um dealt with if you look at the title
of six
here i am with my glasses and font signs
664 9a
this it specifically deals with
the filed electronically
and then so i i sort of
saw it differently representative barry
um yeah i'm looking at line 23
um it says printed so would there be a
this is a good question for all of our
lawyers president
our attorneys um is there a difference
between britain printed
i i'm asking generally i i don't know
this is a this is
this one's uh this one's well well
i don't know they're probably i just
don't know what it is
if somebody can hand write in eight
point font
that's you know what at that point they
should be able to send it in
yeah well i would assume that written
refers to
graphologically and printed refers to
printed
that would be my um that would be my
belief but um
you know i've been wrong before it it
also
says on
line 31 that the candidate shall be
responsible for ensuring the report
is legible and it gives the secretary of
state or attorney general's office
uh to me the discretion to inform the
yeah right like this gives them a little
t
yeah i think reasonable people know when
now we're talking politics and craziness
representative sandler
uh yes ma'am i'm gonna take off my
former lawyer hat here and just use a uh
obsessive wordsmith interpretation
but legible means legible someone's
handwriting might be more legible than
someone else's printing
and more legible than certain small
fonts that we get off of our
computers or a typewriter or what have
you the operative term
is legible if it isn't legible
everything else falls by the wayside
all right we're putting that in the
record representative sandler we're not
taking many notes today
but that's going in
[Music]
all right i'm not seeing anything so
we'll move on to part five this is the
last section
is therefore yeah there is a part yeah
there is yeah
part four in regards to optional town
meeting procedures
um this dealt with the
representative sandler you're back on on
deck
um the prior years versus the prior
years
then i see that uh cordell johnstone
from the nhma is also with us who had
commented on this
before so i'm going to defer to
committee members as to whether that
needs anything
or not anybody think that needs a change
representative sandler thank you
i need you to unmute representatives
great thank you now you're on
thank you uh was the question whether
are we still on the legibility of this
uh
no no no we're on now we're on the next
the the issue of
a community being able to expend funds
before that fiscal year's budget
is approved and it's supposed to be at a
level
that is considered to be reasonable in
light of prior years budgets
and the issue came up in the word
i raised it i was the pain and i think i
was corrected as to the intent by
cordell johnstone
in regards to years on line five
year apostrophe yes as compared to years
with the plural apostrophe
okay years would be the plural you're
right if it's being compared to
a series of two or four or eight or
however many previous years
you would probably want to go back to
those years and determine what
percentage
of the uh votes were affected by it
if it says apostrophe s that that means
we're talking about a particular year
and its ownership of the question that's
going on there
so we could talk about last year's
budget thank you or prior
years plural where we would have to
probably go back and do some kind of a
statistical analysis
right and my concern is because this
issue is generally raised by people who
are very suspicious of what their
municipal leaders are doing in
expenditures
and my concern is and cordell i hope
you're on
when you said prior years
to me that left it wide open to any
prior year
and so if you had big spending five
years ago but the prior year had been
pretty
lean you could argue that
a higher expenditure level until the
budget was approved was consistent with
a prior year budget five years ago
so i had thought that if you were going
to make it
if you were going to make a change it
should have been the prior
fiscal year's appropriations
not prior years so let me
open that up to comment representative
growing
yeah i i felt the same way madam chair
um and i think if we took out
the years where it's located and we read
this
in light of prior appropriations and
expenditures for the same purposes
during the same period
of the immediately prior fiscal period
and that would if the fiscal period is
more than one year
it would take care of that but it would
it would
clearly relate to the immediately prior
um i see that mr johnstone from the new
municipal association is with us i've
asked him if he if he can unmute um
if you want to comment please yeah
um hi and and thank you for um
inviting me uh i my point is simply
that the language ought to be clarified
uh because on line five it says the
current law says
in light of prior year apostrophe s
and you need i think it needs to be
clear that we're
either we're referring to just the last
year singular or we're referring to
a series of prior years plural
and the way it's written right now it's
it's unclear because it
it says prior year apostrophe s
if you want to refer to just one year
you should say
the prior year apostrophe
s if you want to refer to several you
should say
prior years s apostrophe
so so if you don't like changing year
apostrophe s to years
s apostrophe then i think what you want
to do is insert
the word the before prior
in light of the prior year
apostrophe s so it's clear that you're
just referring to
last year would it
court it all if i could speak up and ask
this question school
you know in my town my fiscal year
corresponds to a calendar year so
there's no question about what you would
be referring to for a year
our school district encompasses two
calendar years but is one fiscal
sense to have the word
fiscal associated with year as suggested
by representative growing i i think it's
fine to include the word
the word fiscal and in fact the language
that he suggested
i don't remember it exactly but it
sounded it sounded fine to me
my point is just simply simply clarify
whether you're referring to
one year one fiscal year or or several
fiscal years
and and i don't think i have a strong
opinion as to which it should be
it just ought to be clear one way or the
other
so if you wanted to say in light of the
prior
that would be i think that would be fine
thank you representative tarosian thank
you i had
a question for mr johnson i may so um
i guess one of the questions was
what was the intent just the prior year
or or
to be several prior years or years
that's
that was number one number two uh the
beginning of the fiscal year are there
some towns or
um cities that start their fiscal year
prior to january first
uh yeah there are um
most of the towns are on a calendar
fiscal year
but there are a handful that have a june
uh rather july one to june 30 fiscal
year
okay so it's a follow-up the id this
is address those towns that started
there they say the 2021 budget prior to
january of 2021 then
this is the reason well the the main
reason
if you forget about the change on line
five the main reason for the change on
lines three and four
is to is to extend
the benefit that is currently available
only to
towns with a calendar fiscal year
to extend that to those that have
a june 30 fiscal year as well
because what happened last year
and it was very unusual obviously but
because of the pandemic there were some
towns
with a june 30 fiscal year that had to
postpone their town meeting
until july or august so they were
adopting their budget after the fiscal
year begins
which they don't ordinarily do towns
that are on a calendar fiscal year
always adopt their budget after the
after the fiscal year begins the fiscal
year begins january 1 but we have our
so thank you and the couple so yeah and
the couple of towns that i can think of
that have a meeting later than march
have their fiscal year beginning july 1.
so
up until last year this was not an issue
so this would clarify it correct
all right thank you thank you any other
questions or comments
madam chair questions procedurally
sure um so
what would happen in a town and i
forgive me i have never
lived in a town i've lived in a city
what would happen in a town where you
did want to make a significant increase
in a portion of the budget how would you
go about doing that
you need to do it as part of your budget
this is
so if on and on cordell i'm jumping in
here correct me if i'm on
as a former selectman i might have
decide that i want to spend
10 times more than i did last year on my
road plan
okay everybody wants a new road and i
decide i ran on new roads i'm going to
give
everybody a new road my budget
would have a huge increase
in my public works budget for that plan
what this would mean is if the prior
year
i wasn't spending at 10 times the rate
right i'm proposing the increase
i can only spend at the rate of the
prior year until the voters go
and approve the increase and then
whenever my meeting is then i can go out
and order my asphalt and spend at that
rate and if they don't approve it
i've kept myself at the prior year's
level so i'm not running into a
budget disaster by doing a huge
expenditure and then having the voters
say
hey we're not going to give you that
increase thank you cordell did i get
that
yes yes that's right if if you want uh
basically
uh you need to you need to be careful
about your expenditures
between january 1 and the town meeting
and as the law says be consistent with
the prior year's expenditures if you
want to increase something tenfold
you very well better wait until
town meeting when the voters approve the
budget and then you can spend whatever
representative hamlet thank you madam
chair
i i also think it's important to put the
the word immediate
in there if you're really referring to
the immediate past year
somebody else brought that up i think
representative sandler
is that right with year or years so
i'm i'm hoping that representative
growing has volunteered to do an
amendment along the lines of the words
that he suggested i think it was he
um
okay representative quailly thank you
madam chairman
uh i agree that clarification is really
needed and i think
the the the introduction of the word
fiscal is really important here and and
it is needed for the towns that have
their fiscal year
begin july 1st and i thought
representative grohn's
amendment did a good job of clarifying
and it's important to clarify it because
it
it needs to be clear otherwise i'm also
a former select when i did one term here
in rindge
and things need to be very clear or the
possibility for conflict and dissension
rises very quickly so this needs this
fix needs to be done
thank you all right anybody else on part
5 of sb 83
i'm not seeing anything so we're going
to move on
to the last bill for work session the
last
senate bill for consideration by this
committee
that would be sb 89
sb 89 would had a public hearing
on april 23rd
this is a bill of omnibus
legislation relating to
the chief city chief election officer
dealing with photographs within the
guard rail
allowing reprocessing of absentee
ballots
establishing a committee and the duties
of the registrar of probate um
representative bergeron when we get to
the part that you have an amendment can
you please speak up
um unmute yourself and speak up because
of the computer that i'm on i'm not
going to be able to dual screen very
easily so
i'm going to need you to take the lead
on that amendment so part one
relative to the city chief election
officer this appeared to be a change
the term being used as a descriptor
committee members
anybody
okay not seeing any
i'm gonna move on to part two regarding
taking up photographs within the
guardrail
i think we sort of discussed what the
purpose and
function of this one this is separate
from taking a picture
of your own ballot any questions or
comments
i'm not seeing any part three in regards
to
the pre-processing of absentee ballots
comments questions
this is like the calm before the storm
[Music]
okay sure representative bergeron you go
ahead with your amendment
okay thank you madam chair um
the intent as i understand it from the
sponsor in part
was to allow for cities and towns to be
able to reach out
to voters who were voting absentee
whose paperwork or affidavits weren't
filled out properly
and give them an opportunity to correct
um
those errors prior to the ballots being
counted on election day
and that's the concept i think i would
hope that all of us support to try and
make it work
it was the approach to it the logistics
of it that i
had some concerns about um
there seemed to be some conflicting
language in the
uh original senate bill 89 as amended
for example it was in one section it was
saying that
if someone was voting in person the
clerk could
take a look at the affidavit make sure
it was
filled out properly but at the same time
was saying in that section that the
clerk had to have a policy
providing a 24-hour notice that this be
done
it also provided that at five o'clock
the day after the uh the day before an
election
that the moderator would be processing
these
and you know presumably to to find
errors that occurred in the affidavits
and then the clerk would have to contact
these people to
try and correct the paperwork of course
the problem with that is the night
before an election the election
officials are probably trying to set up
their polling places
and uh you know in practice once the
office is closed on that monday night
there's no one going to be even if the
clerk can reach out to these people
there's not going to be anyone there to
accept the correction
um and if that we're telling them to go
to the polls on election day
to uh to vote in person the next day
um you know again you have the problem
well they're voting absentee because
they can't go to the polls
so the amendment that i was proposing
kind of took a look at
what we did during the covet
experiences last fall which would allow
the moderator to do the pre-processing
on certain days after the checklist has
been
certified by the supervisors of the
checklist
it eliminated the the night before which
is monday because now
the purpose is to try and find out where
there have been errors
that have occurred it still directs the
town of city clerk to try and reach out
to these people
to see if we can get their paperwork
corrected it also adds the word
affidavit envelope
and application because sometimes it's
not just the
envelope that's a problem it might be
the application itself
so we're asking the moderator to look at
both of those
it's focusing on the moderator doing
this because under state laws the
moderator who ultimately has to make the
decision
as to whether or not a voter's paperwork
has been properly executed and the vote
should be counted
so even if the clerk was doing a lot of
preliminary work ultimately the
moderator has to go through all of those
envelopes
and make sure that the paperwork has
been properly executed
the other provision i i
put in there is and and representative
hamlin as well
is to say that if the moderator want to
hold sessions prior to the
uh certification the checklist they
could do so they just couldn't mark up
the checklist
until that session that occurs after
which is mandatory
that occurs after the uh checklist has
been posted
uh i think i've covered about the key
things i i mean i try to
preserve the intent of senator gray's
proposal and try and
resolve some of the logistical problems
i saw with it
using as a model what was done with
house bill 1266
i'd like to think that that we were able
to accomplish that
and i guess if if you know other
committee members have any questions or
or input on this approach i would
certainly
uh be happy to try and answer those
committee members
um is representative mooney in
in lobby because i know she had a
conversation with her
clerk um and i i
wondered if she was available to share
it
yes we can okay
yes i was contacted by my town's
moderator
she did have three very specific
issues with regard to the bill and i
think that
frankly representative bergeron's
amendment covers a couple of them
i'd like to really get them verbatim so
could you just give me one moment
sure in the meantime representative
tarosian did you have a comment on this
section
yes um we heard in testimony on um
on page two i guess of this uh section
um line 17 that the town and city clerks
are the
designee shall open out envelopes of all
absentee ballots received prior to 5 pm
on the day
prior to election day we heard testimony
from from
some town clerks one in particular was
that the town clerk from derry
who had a concern with that
um being required that it shall and that
the word may
may be better in that regard and so i
didn't know if the
if representative bergeron's amendment
would address that section
or not uh if i may respond madam chair
sure representative bertrand um i had
that question of senator gray during his
testimony i said
was it your intent to make this
mandatory for all elections and he said
yes
so i kept in the language shell
and what i did in my amendment is that
say after the checklist has been posted
or certified by the supervisors of the
checklist the moderators
shall hold a session to review these uh
you know open the elder envelopes and
review the affidavits
and uh i mean his as i understood it his
intent was to ensure
that election officials would try and uh
make corrections to any of the paperwork
that voters may have inadv inadvertently
made errors to
to allow their votes to be cast on
election day so
thank you representative mooney do you
have your notes
thank you madam chair so the first one
is to allow but
and that's in line with what
representative terresian just brought up
okay number two
is to allow processing
during the thursday through saturday
prior to election
not monday and i see that very
clearly in the bergeron hamlet amendment
page 1 and 16 through
19. and then
issue 3 allow challengers during
pre-processing
madam chair yet my amendment did not
address the issue of
of challenging um challenges occur
actually at the polls as the voter's
name is being announced
and that would continue to be the
practice even with those
absentee ballots that were pre-processed
based on again what i think senator
gray's intent was
i tried to preserve that intent in the
amendment
representative bergeron and i apologize
for not being able to
see your amendment um there was a
comment
during during our public hearing on
the second page of the bill of the part
page three i think line 21 about the
moderator shall
then mark the chest list and there was
suggestion that that
be changed to the moderator or the
moderators designee
does anybody recall that or think it's
material
if this section of the bill is going to
be changed
i i think i did say throughout my
amendment
the moderator or the moderator's
designee
okay great really does in the
pre-processing of absentee ballots
and and i if i may add during the public
hearing one of the members of the
committee asked
how many people are we really talking
about in trying to reach out
who may not have filled out the
affidavits or the paperwork properly
um my my best guess based on experience
is that
that is less than half of one percent
the uh of the absentee ballots received
the the real workload is the opening and
the reviewing of all the absentee
ballots not necessarily
thank you representative groan
thank you madam chair um i have a
question for representative bergeron if
he's willing to take it
sure go ahead uh
do i understand that your amendment
would establish
certain days and possibly times for the
uh for the pre-processing
as opposed to sort of an open notice
process
uh yes the uh the pre-processing the
mandatory session
should not occur until the supervisors
of the checklist have
have certified uh the checklist for use
at the election and that usually
will occur seven to ten days before the
date of the election
um i looked at the dates actually the
day
selected for house bill 1266 which was
the um
the covid bill dealing with
pre-processing of absentee ballots
it specifically said thursday friday
saturday or monday
so in modeling that language i included
the words thursday friday or saturday
prior to the time established for
the date of the election so yes there
are specific days
it really doesn't matter i suppose as
long as it occurs after the checklist
follow up go ahead representative
one of the uh concerns that i have
with the uh probably the main concern
with the pre-processing
is that when uh when a notice is given
um that that notice
unless somebody is necessarily really
watching for it they may not see it
election day is always the same tuesday
and people know that and i'm wondering
if we could specify
a certain like on say thursday and
friday at 10 o'clock
that ten or ten o'clock and following
that
that this would be done so that we
establish a very
definitive time that is the same in all
towns and cities
that people then know okay this is this
is when the pre-processing is going to
be done and it becomes a habit
as opposed to something that can be
announced
and changed by every town and in any
situation
if with permission let me chime in on
that one
i do sort of like that but
i will tell you that the last september
election that
after labor day the tuesday after labor
day if you recall the primary
um we were setting up
actually the thursday night and friday
before the election
because that's when we had staff
available
and could do it and of course school
wasn't really in session
that's my i will tell you that's sort of
my concern one of the
the things about doing these is your
clerk slash moderators ability to find
volunteers
to come in and do this process and
if we handicap i don't want to say
handicap if we limit it to a particular
day you may end up with communities that
just say
we might like to do it but we there's i
can't get enough volunteers that day
or my moderator's not available or
um but i agree that it needs it
there needs to be some
parameters on when it occurs
if i made madam chair just to add
house bill 1266 modeled some of what was
in
house bill 556 which i sponsored last
session to allow for pre-processing of
ballots
and during all the discussions and
committee public hearings
some of the issues you raised actually
were discussed that there should be
specific days
identified thursday and friday became
two of those days that were identified
and then saturday was
was added because one of the senators
felt well maybe this should be done at
the polling sites
and since so many polling sites are in
the schools it couldn't be done during
while school was in session and
therefore they threw in the saturday
so there was some consideration given to
try and identify
a very limited number of days when that
that could occur
um i don't know if there's really a
perfect solution for all communities as
representative griffin kind of alluded
to
okay thank you madam chair uh yes i just
wanted to reiterate that um
when the the clerk i mean it worked
really well in the
in the last election in the in the in
the covid
covert election um so when the clerk
announces that
the date of the pre-processing he or she
also has to announce the time
so the the clerk makes that very clear
that you know there's a date and time
of the where you know where the when the
pre-processing will occur in the
location where it will occur
so i don't think that needs to be a
statewide
you know specific rule but the town
clerks do know that they have to make it
very clear that
the date time and place of where the
pre-processing
will occur thank you
representative grohan one other
uh question on this a concern and that
is that if we
if we uh introduce may versus shell
and some towns do go through the
pre-processing and allow
voters to uh correct their application
and other towns choose not to then are
are we going to run into a situation of
of
uh that that voters and those in the in
the first group of towns
will have a an advantage over those in
the other towns and is the court going
i think that is a point raise and one of
the reasons that senator gray uh
used the word shell in his language
representative taurosian
thank you madam chair um since that
brought up about um there being an
inconsistency
this bill or this part of the bill has
has that built in
in that in essence it rewards
voters who vote early that have a chance
to have the information corrected
when those that don't on their absentee
ballots come in
um after that date they don't have the
advantage
of um of having their missing signature
an incorrect name and so forth verified
so
we already have that problem as as the
um yes to build on what trojan said i
think there's
a big equal protection issue here um
specifically for those ballots that come
in late
um it's it you know we're
the the kova 19 election 2020 is getting
referenced a lot
in which there was a surge of absentee
ballots um you can most certainly make
the argument that when a third of the
electorate was voting with absentee
ballots
um that that this was necessary but i
i don't think going into 2022 that we're
going to see that sort of turnout again
and that sort of reliance on absentee
ballots
i also have serious trepidations about
moving
election day away from election day that
has been
a new hampshire tradition going back
over a hundred years that election day
happens on election day and
we're not trying to stop anybody from
voting with an absentee that's their
right
um certain people are not available at
the polls on that day and they have to
cast an absentee ballot but we need to
treat everybody equally we treat
everybody the same
and i believe we need to make sure that
we're keeping with the
new hampshire tradition of voting on
election day when possible
and that's why i want that's why i'm i'm
a big believer in as much
as much election activity needs to
happen on election day as is possible
i think in the future we are going to
have electronic poll books i think those
are going to be commonplace
in if we pass this this previous bill
probably in six years
that's going to dramatically reduce the
amount of staff or volunteers that are
needed on election day because the lines
are going to be much shorter there's no
there's not going to be a through d
anymore there's going to be four lines
you walk up you go to whatever one's
open
and you vote so i i think we're moving
towards addressing a lot of the problems
that pre-processing is attempting
to deal with already and
i i think we're kind of moving away from
that traditional new hampshire
experience of voting on election day
when possible
thank you other comments
so representative bergeron has his
amendment he's um the committee members
have it
if people have further changes or other
amendments
um they want to do i would suggest
either working
off of representative bergeron's
amendment with his amendment
okay um the next section
all right the next section of sb 89
is part 4 which has to do with the
committee to study post-election audit
counting devices
um and some recount
discrepancy authorization investigation
to the attorney general's office
comments from committee members
representative bergeron
uh thank you madam chair my comments
pertain specifically to the first
section of part
four which is on page 3 starting with
line 27
establishing a committee to study
post-election audit counting devices
last session senate bill 283
required that the secretary of state uh
conduct a study
of high-speed optical scan ballot
counting devices
to assess the feasibility of using such
equipment in a post-election audit
that report was due november 1st
uh but given the challenges posed
during the last fall election by uh
covet and a lot of the preparations the
secretary of state had to make to
to address those issues at the polls
it wasn't released until march 23rd
senator gray's bill was actually
introduced on january 26th
prior to the secretary of state's report
you know in looking at this section i
think basically senator gray
is asking to establish a special
committee to do what the secretary of
state has already done
so i'm not so sure there's this value in
creating
that committee at this time we have
retained
representative lang's bill in our
committee
to address the issues of post-election
audits
i'm thinking that perhaps that's really
all we need we don't need to establish
another committee
to do the work that was done last
session with senate bill 283 which by
the way
other comments on this part or
representative bergeron's comments that
i think were
terrific
representative teresian thank you madam
chair and and uh
question to representative bergeron that
senate bill he referenced
that the study has been completed was
that was that a similar
type um committee um by that i mean did
did it have um um you know a couple
members of the senate
uh three members from the house and so
forth or was it was it a standard
uh study commission as this proposes to
do
uh no it wasn't a study committee it
simply directed the secretary of state
to uh
conduct a study as to the feasibility of
using these devices
as post for post-election audits so the
secretary of state was charged with uh
finding vendors to do it to conduct the
studies to use
ballots from previous elections to see
what kinds of results they were
i'd be happy to forward a copy of that
report the secretary of state's report
to all members of the committee
so that you could see what it entails
it's a 44-page report but 37 of the
pages
are the vendor's uh data which are
attached to deputy scanlan's
commentary i'd love to get a copy thank
you representative
thank you for emailing that to committee
members there was
a request for vendors to come and do a
trial run uh the secretary of state
conducted it up at the state archives
there were two vendors i think that were
able to
become um another vendor was unable to
attend you might re it
occurred last fall um whereas has been
referenced there were a lot of competing
interests going on for these
vendors that have these machines um i
had the opportunity to be there for part
of it
um it was pretty impressive to watch
um ballots which were
put in huge stacks into
high speed readers and how fast they
were processed
and that the machines could
pick up questions that were then
pulled out which allowed them whoever
the decision maker would have been
to sit at a machine and actually look
electronically at the ballot to make a
determination for example whether the
circle was
adequately filled in it was pretty
impressive
so i just sort of threw that out
and that was as representative bergeron
said as a result of senator gray's bill
other questions or comments from
committee members
okay madam chair uh representative
growing
up so i agree with uh senator
with representative bergeron on on that
section one
of section three but it seems to me
that section two we're on section four
excuse me section one i mean part four
okay yeah so excuse me
on section one of part four
asking for a study committee i agree
uh on that part that i think we should
just
deal with whatever we want to do with
this on representative lang's bill
but then if you go to uh line 15 on page
four and then
line um 35 on page four it seems that
those are
very different topics that aren't part
of the study committee if i'm reading it
correctly
um so those are
those really are it appears to me not
related to the
yes
and i i i also recall that on
on the lion 30 where it starts on line
35 that madam chair you had
some concern about the about
uh the wording
of the authority given to the ballot law
commission as being a bit broad
um yes i did thank you for pointing that
out let's go back as senator
i mean representative growing points out
that representative bergeron's
comments in regards to the committee
dealt with only section one
of part four so i'm going to move on to
section two um
and
that section deals with recounts
um and i'm not
i don't show that there was much
question or comment
on this section does anybody have
anything on this
change
deputy scanlan i believe you're still on
the line if you could
speak as to the purpose and whether or
not
section two of part four has any
concerns for the secretary of state's
office since they
are in charge of recounts
yes thank you madam chair um
this portion of the bill
and section four is uh
is a reaction to uh what's happening
with uh wyndham right now and a
disparity between
the the count on election night and the
recount
um and
you know the the the the process
uh took place as it's doing the statute
where there was election night count
there was a recount that showed a large
disparity which
is which is unusual it's not unheard of
but it's unusual
um the bell law commission heard the
appeal
and they ruled that you know that there
was no
change in the outcome of the election
after the recount and and they declared
uh the winners uh you know that were
chosen on the night of recount so
the question then became well you know
when when
all of the republican candidates jump up
roughly 300 votes
and the one democrat candidate went down
99. what was the reason for that and
deputy scanlon i don't deputy scanlon i
i didn't phrase my question well enough
for a moment
before we get to i think section three
the ballot law commission
i wanted to know whether the secretary
of state's office had any
comment or opinion on the ex expansion
in regards to the conduct of a recount
in section two
expanding the language the ballots cast
for such
office or question including votes cast
for the candidates or question
on the ballot write in votes and not
counted from
over votes or under votes language
because i didn't really i don't have any
notes indicating
that there was really much said about
this and i'm not sure what the problem
is it's trying to address
okay so the the law currently says that
the ballots
that are counted in a recount are the
ballots that were
cast uh in the election
um and it's as simple as that so when we
conduct a recount
we do not count the ballots
that were not used in the election
um and there are some that believe that
that uh we should account for the whole
universe of ballots that were sent to
the top uh
for the election whether they were cast
or not
so um
i mean it's up to the legislature to
decide whether we should go through the
exercise of counting
ballots that were not used or not uh it
will
require more time to do that and
we try to be as efficient as possible
during the recount so that's what that
part of the bill does
but deputy scale and if i can continue
this with the committee's indulgence
this doesn't talk about ballots this
talks about
votes so this means that this would
direct
to count votes that were
legally not part of the vote count on
well i'm looking at if you're looking at
on page four lines 19 and 20.
is that is that what we're talking about
yes
yes uh including votes cast for the
candidates
or the question write-in votes
and we count those uh and not voted
resulting from over votes or undervotes
so that would be
an additional requirement that we do not
do now
where if let's say in in
if there's a town where you elect four
and the voter only cast votes for three
then we would have to count that no vote
in a no vote category
and then in addition to that if it was
vote for four
and the voter voted for five
we would also have to account for
the fact for that fifth vote um
and so the they're again that would uh
require additional time it's not
something that we do
right now if they is under
counted we simply count the ballots that
were cast
if the ballot was over voted we simply
count that ballot as
no votes being cast for any candidate um
yeah but it doesn't say ballot it says
votes
that's my concern my concern here
is this appears to be directing counting
those
votes not those ballots
so i understand that there's a concern
that
whether or not there's a check as to
whether the total amount of ballots that
a town receives an election
are the same as the amount of ballots
that might come back for recount
but to me that's very different than
votes and my concern is is that if we're
directing you
to count votes over voted
undervoted that we're not part of the
tape totals plus
they can't recounts we are now
having a recount with the fifth column
so to speak
total votes possibly for a candidate
that were not counted legally
i understand what you're saying madam
chair and and i think that
that this language does do that it's
okay that's all i need that's all i
needed to hear okay
thank you any other questions from
committee members
all right i'm just i i will say flat out
i think that is a huge
mistake um
[Music]
and i will either or ask somebody else
to
to take this proposed language out
because i think
raising the possibility that we're going
to count
at an official recount votes that were
not part of the official election
results
creates a huge problem i don't have an
issue with ballots and maybe after the
audit
is done and we have an audit report
there will be a process to do that
that's clearly delineated
but i think allowing that possibility of
a result without
those guard rails so to speak
is incredibly uh
dangerous as to confidence in election
results
all right so that was section two
section three deputy scanlan um
i think you had started to talk about
and
there was language that was somewhat
referred to
in regards to significant and
unexplained discrepancy as to what that
means and i have to tell you i i
don't know that i want a bill that has
anything related to the possibility of
could undermine public confidence
because
i think that's pretty broad too deputy
scanlan
thank you madam chair and i just follow
along the line that you were going
is that this is a reaction to what's
occurring in windham right now
and i think that it would make sense for
that process to play out
before we start engaging in a
conversation of
you know what post election
and recount and bow law commission
appeals processes
should look at uh look like um the
danger here is that
you know we get away from from a quick
finality to the election
and get into a process that could be
really drawn out
and um you know i think that again we
should look at
how the wyndham situation plays out
before we
uh start changing the law relative to
post
you know post-election and recount
procedures
other members with comments on section
three
of sb 89 part
i'm not seeing any and i don't see
representative lane's hand
so part four of part
four of sb or section four of part four
of sb 89
starts on page five of the bill i have
as printed
and it deals with the attorney general's
office with enforcement
of election laws
common
my notes reflect that currently the
authority to seal or unseal ballot boxes
less rests with the secretary of state's
office
that this allows the attorney general to
unseal and resale seal the ballot boxes
um i this i guess maybe is for the
secretary of state or other lawyers on
the committee um the attorney general's
office is usually
part of the enforcement arm of
election laws not the participant
and i'm wondering what impact having
them
physically involved in
ballot sorting counting
anybody have a comment i don't recall
hearing a lot about that
prior to today was that
i don't have any notes specifically
i i agree there i just i have i have
myself
highlighted the attorney general may
unseal and reseal
ballot boxes because that was apparently
a flag of a concern of mine
no no remarked as well i don't recall
anybody
maybe they did i don't know i have a
representative growing i i do recall i
i'm i'm not sure if uh senator gray
spoke about this
at the hearing or if it was a discussion
i had with him
after the hearing but
the section four is an enabling
section for section three
as i understand it if you look at line
eight
uh through ten it says that the the
authority uh at the end of line eight
whenever the ballot law commission
requests an investigation be conducted
the attorney general
may steal or unseal and the
argument was this time
that the attorney general said he did
not have the authority to unseal and
reseal the ballot boxes
so this was to give him the authority if
the
election law commission said hey we want
this looked into
it gave the attorney general and rsa
76-c
the right to do that i believe that's
the intent that it's
it's really it's really the enabling
part for
section three thank you representative
grohan i would point out that i would
argue it does not
actually limit it to that it actually
gives the attorney general
upon his or her own motion so
it is not just authorizing about law
commission to direct the attorney
general's office to do something
which i don't know that that's a policy
that we want to adopt it allows the
attorney general to do it
on their own motion again i'm not sure
that's
a policy we want to adopt attorney
excuse me
uh let me look here representative
terozian
yeah i was just going to say madam chair
that um yeah it looks to
make um the process we went through with
senate bill 43
um if this if this windham
problem were to crop up in the future um
without
this part of uh of senate bill 89
in place we'd have to go through if we
house so desired we'd have to go through
the same process again
to um to get those ballots on sale this
in my opinion looks to attempt to
put in law the ability for the
attorney general's office to address
this in the future were to
come up no i don't know whether you know
if limits are not limits
that that appears to me to be the reason
why that's in there
what i can tell that was
senator gray's intent uh for my
discussion with him
that's what it looks like thank you
just to clarify it's my understanding
that the issue is
ballot boxes because there's specific
statutes in regard to the retention of
ballots and how that is handled
and that the attorney general's office
now and in fact has um
done books records paper
documentary materials so i mean it's
sort of a mishmash is
what i would sort of say i'm not sure
i i i understand the issue that came up
but i'm not sure from a policy
standpoint
i want the attorney general whoever that
might be
to have the ability to go get ballot
boxes and unseal them
for whatever they might think needs to
be investigated because
as written this might require the ballot
law commission to do the direction
madam chair would you be okay with this
if we eliminated
no probably not because i think to be
honest with you
um you're taking that you're making a
major change
in the ballot law commission
authority um and i come back to
what's a significant and unexplained
discrepancy
i mean you know other people are not
raising a major
issue with this so i mean that's part of
having this
discussion so people can raise issues
that maybe they hadn't thought about or
maybe hanging out on the limb about to
fall off the branch all by themselves
well there's also the issue of the
discretion that
that language arguably grants to the
attorney general
okay i think those are concerns
does the secretary of state's office um
have a position that they want to
set forth in regards to this provision
thank you madam chair we have concerns
about this portion
of the bill as well for the you know
from the items that you mentioned um i i
will let the committee know that
that right now there is an opportunity
to unseal
ballot boxes if there are documents or
equipment
uh that were left in them after the
election
that are needed after the election and
that process involves the secretary of
state going
to the town with witnesses on the boxes
to retrieve those items
and then seal them it's getting specific
to the attorney general
if there is a an investigation a
criminal investigation
that they are undertaking related to uh
ballots or an election they do have the
opportunity to go to the court
uh and have the court grant an order
that would allow them to open those
boxes for that specific purpose
aside from that the boxes after election
and all appeals are over are sealed
and they are kept for the mandatory 22
months as required by federal law
after the election at which point they
are destroyed
town election ballots are kept for 60
days
thank you comments or questions from
committee members
okay i'm gonna move on to section
five which is a relative to the duties
of the registrars of probate this
actually probably did get the most
public participation of all of the parts
of this bill as i recall um
representative tarosian thank you madam
chair
um yeah well this this part five
certainly uh makes this a true omnibus
building that it doesn't have a lot to
do with election law as far as i can
tell
but um but having said that um
it is in the new hampshire constitution
that each county have a
register of probate that does
the work that needs to be that's
required under probate
um and in 2011 we heard testimony that
that
uh responsibility got shifted to the
circuit court
area and um you know there's certainly
in my mind there's some merit to putting
it back where the constitution says it
should be
for one reason um like the rest of us in
the room i
took an oath to uphold the new hampshire
constitution and it seems like
this got put in the wrong place as far
as the constitution was concerned
but the other part is that we did also
hear testimony that
suggested and i've never been through
the probate process so i can't speak
um you know firsthand on that
um is less responsive than it may
have been in may and should be if it
were if the process was where
the constitution said it should be with
the
um the register of probate um
at the county level so that's my comment
i you know i don't i'm not sure
um you know the best way to handle this
i know there's problems with with money
um because this doesn't seem to fund
if if we decide that this is what we
should do
there is not money to fund that that um
activity
at the county level um and so that would
be something that would have to be
addressed
but anyway those are some of my thoughts
representative mcdonald thank you madam
chairman
um i've uh you know talked to a number
of people on this
on this issue and you know
this whole situation was changed
originally for a reason
expecting that effectively and i
understand it's in the constitution an
effort was made to take it out of the
constitution and we know how
constitutional amendments how successful
they usually are
but to bring this position back without
a support staff
without proper funding without any
training without even a clear place
as to where that person is going to be
working i don't think makes any sense at
i i guess my point on this section would
be you either want it in or you want it
out
i don't know that it appeared to be a
section that as
to the um
content of it itself that there was a
lot of wordsmithing
representative growing representative
brown can you unmute
we we haven't heard you you need to add
me great thank
thank you yeah i agree with
representative mcdonald
um that our constitution requires this
and i wasn't very excited about it in
2011 when we
i remember dealing with this when i was
in the senate but at this point
it seems to me kind of like um
requiring us to reintroduce brakeman
that
um would reside in the caboose of a
train
that would have no function other than
to sit there
and i the the the responsibilities of
this
of this position have been given to the
court and
for the most part i think we're going to
have a person without a position
other questions or comments other than
that i request
permission to use putting somebody in
the caboose with no breaks
okay uh except except anybody else
we will see it again madam chair no
matter what happens no matter what
happens
we will we will maybe not in election
law but
it will be seen again all right any
other
comments from community members all
right we've had a
i i think we've had a consensus on a
couple of sections of bills
as to changes that may need to be made
we've had a couple of volunteers for
amendments we've had somebody
already do an amendment um
and maybe persons are going to do other
amendments on on different parts
we will not be having an executive
session next week
um i'm not quite sure at this point when
it's going to be scheduled but it will
not be next week and part of the point
of that
was so that if people wanted to do
further amendments
or have some more discussions about this
bill you have the ample opportunity to
before executive session because i do
anticipate we're going to have to deal
with
um probably series of amendments on
various parts of these bills
so i will let you know as soon as i've
got it figured out for executive session
i don't anticipate a need to meet as a
committee before the executive session
anybody else have any other business
they want to bring before the committee
this morning or this afternoon we did
make it into afternoon
i'm sure could i just ask that if people
are preparing amendments that they
distribute them as promptly as possible
yeah thank you and pam um if you're
still on
yes i just want to make it thank you
um i want to make it clear that as to
these
amendments we'd be dealing with them as
we would with amendments in
any bill if we're addressing as
particular part of a bill
and we have successive successive
amendments um that they would
essentially be
overlaid as to the previous amendments
um and then incorporated into
the final house bill as amended do i
have that process correct
or not well if i understood you
um yes i mean i think
if you have multiple amendments
that are adopted to one of the omnibus
bills they would need to be unified
after the executive session into a
single amendment
that would appear in the house calendar
they would not be
remain as separate amendments for the
individual parts of the omnibus they'd
all be
rolled into one but each individual
amendment that is worked on
you know it makes sense to to address
them
as a single part okay
that's what you're asking and i i would
ask that that any amendments that come
through um if people could include me on
the distribution list i'm not on the
committee distribution list but it would
be helpful if
if i had them so i can
make sure they're in the the room for
people to come in person
on the day of the exec and also have
them to to make that
combined amendment thanks
all right thank you all right anybody
else have any questions or comments
all right i'm not seeing any thank you
everybody for
coming this morning early afternoon to
talk about these bills we'll get an
executive
session scheduled sometime in may
i will let you know as soon as i've got
my calendar figured out
enjoy the rest of your day everybody